quatre nageuses du centre d'entraînement
de l'équipe nationale de natation
artistique canada en entassés elle brise
le silence malgré la peur de
représailles
nous avons accepté de changer leur nom
et leur voix
ça fait trop longtemps que ça dure au
sein de cette organisation
il règne un environnement toxique en
natation artistique assez c'est assez
il faut que ça change selon ces nageuses
l'incident qui a déclenché la fermeture
du centre a troublé plusieurs athlètes
dans une conversation avec des membres
de l'équipe l'entraîneur chef gabor
hasardeuse aurait tenu des propos
qualifiés de racistes et des nues il
parlait de ce qui se passe en chine et
du mouvement black ice man 2 et des
musulmans
il a dit que tous les musulmans sont des
extrémistes puis il a ajouté
à quand remonte la dernière fois où j'ai
vu un blanc provoquer un écrasement
d'avion
lorsque confronté par une nageuse zardoz
serait devenu agressif verbalement il
répondu
nous sommes dans un pays libre que dire
ce que je veux ci dessus pour me dire ce
qu'est un discours n et u du chan orange
n'est pas surprise par les derniers
événements et l'a annoncé sa retraite il
ya deux mois
entre autres parce que le client au
centre était devenue invivable pour elle
debian est de la violence verbale de
gabode zeiser dont elle aurait été elle
même victime lors d'une compétition en
chine en 2019
ces commentaires auraient été adressés à
des substituts après un échauffement pré
compétition jugée inadéquate ans
l'entraîneur chef
toute l'équipe qui était ce tte
peut-être
dix minutes avant notre compétition et
il y avait différents adultes témoins de
la scène des explications venu plus tard
n'ont pas satisfait ses athlètes
il a juste dit que nous avions tout m'a
compris et qu'ils voulaient dire nous
frapper très fort avec un entraînement
difficile selon ses nageuses du centre
gabor zolder a l'habitude de s'acharner
sur une athlète à la fois patricia se
souvient d'un épisode à hawaï et une
fille a été publiquement humilié pour
son point de vente l'équipe le personnel
était non il voulait que ce soir clark
et steve ou lui de façon publiquement il
le préciser je me sentais mal d'assister
à cette conversation
c'était vraiment inapproprié traiter
ainsi ce genre de sujet ce genre
d'incident aurait fini par alourdir
l'ambiance au quotidien gabor ardeurs
est un entraîneur aux humeurs
changeantes qui s'emporte fréquemment
sur ses nageuses ce qui provoquerait des
larmes et des crises d'anxiété
c'est arrivé qu'il tient prêt ni fille
au point qu'elle fasse des crises de
panique à la piscine ou jenny il
continue tri après les harceler il les
injurier
et les traite de bébé et ont dit
d'arrêter de pleurer et des sources
aisée il serait arrivé à gabor d'y aller
de commentaires à connotation sexuelle
comme cette fois à princeton à l'endroit
de sean hoare m cette chaîne c'est pas
possible
[Musique]
une fois
ce n'est qu'une fois à la retraite
qu'elle dit avoir eu le courage d'en
parler à ses parents
[Musique]
ces nageuses reproche à natation
artistique canada de ne pas avoir pris
la situation suffisamment au sérieux
quand des incidents ont été rapportés
qu'on s'est fait constamment répondre
vous savez il vient d'europe de l'est il
nous faisons souvent rencontré après
coup pour nous faire dire que nous
n'étions pas assez résiliente et que
nous n'arrivions pas à composer avec
l'anxiété et le stress en situation
d'entraînement alors ça nous faisait de
plus en plus tard de dénoncer natation
artistique canada a refusé la demande
d'entrevue en raison de l'examen en
cours dans une déclaration écrite ou
d'entraîneur chef
14h nie en bloc toutes ces allégations
et se dit confiant que le rapport de
l'examen rejettera toute forme d'un
conduit pour leur part si rien ne change
c'est athlètes envisage sérieusement
d'imiter leurs ex coéquipière chant
normande et de prendre elles aussi leur
retraite à moins d'un an des jeux
un reportage de jacinthe ayons aidé yann
sauvé